(ambient music)
- The first one, there were
three people who came up.
It was in a small room with the YMCA.
And just kept doing it.
And I know that some of
you guys have been here
from the beginning.
Remember when we had five,
eight people in the room?
And as a result, now
we have over 80 people,
we're in Indigo.
And it just shows that this
was just a part-time thing
that I've been working on.
Stick with whatever you're doing.
Give it enough time.
You're bound to succeed.
And a lot of entrepreneurs quit too early.
They quit before they
reach the finish line.
So I would encourage you to
stick with it, keep going.
Eventually you'll get
to where you want to go.
- On behalf of all of us,
thank you for the time you've
invested in the seminar.
This is just a small token of appreciation
for love of learning.
(applauding)